journalism is under attack like never
before no post between tear gas fire you
have to have the fact beautiful but
tragic because people are doubting
everything you're the only way of
telling their story how would you
describe this outrage something like an
apocalypse you're gonna be really tired
you're gonna be really scared it's too
dangerous anyone who says they're not
scared is life
anything can happen
did you get hurt i sometimes wonder how
have we managed to get out of
this we do genuinely believe in what we
do he's clearly march's press to show
the truth wow this is absolutely
unbelievable to uncover an injustice
this is the result of ethnic cleansing i
don't think any journalist wants
anything more than that i'm alex
crawford i'm stuart ramsey and this is
hot spots
coming up on hot spots please keep your
feet we're in afghanistan as coalition
forces prepare to withdraw and the
afghan national army has got a very big
problem we witnessed the sudden and
shocking collapse as the taliban take
over i think it's a procession of the
taliban they're coming down the street
uh just next to us
and i returned to report on the reality
of the new regime what a horrible
horrible place
there's no need for this like if you
again i will break everything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
british soldiers tried to maneuver
through ditches and across fields
there's a taliban stronghold in a
compound hidden by a tree line just a
hundred meters away
i actually got to pakistan on 9 11 and
i've been covering afghanistan for all
of the 20 years
oh gosh i don't know how many times i've
been there i've been to afghanistan a
lot our route takes us east to a place
where the afghan government has no remit
where foreign troops steer well clear
i've been told to put on my burqas that
i'm less noticeable
alex and i did a lot of stories that
involved actually interviewing and
meeting the taliban in afghanistan well
it's a helicopter are above us now and
immediately as it arrived
the taliban said that that was the end
of the program that they had to leave
they've shown us how
they plant their improvised bombs this
is what they want the foreigners to see
though they want to show that they are a
fighting force and they're too tough to
be taken on it's sort of been a part of
my almost my entire adult working life
actually i was looking forward to going
back because i knew that it was bubbling
up to be a big big story did we think
kabul was going to fall at that stage no
did we think things were going to change
dramatically within afghanistan 100 i
knew it was coming something big was
coming
[Music]
here we go
good
one of the last times i went to
afghanistan i was um held hostage with
my crew for
most of the day and had to be rescued by
the american military so
going back was quite a big deal
you always going to be a bit nervous
going to somewhere like afghanistan
the real reason why we're going back was
because the american forces were pulling
out and this was opening up a vacuum of
power and the taliban were moving into
that vacuum
the obvious big game of this trip was to
get alex and kev with the taliban
you don't know what you're going to find
on the ground how dangerous things are
you get there and you realise it's a
thriving thriving bustling city
you've got what the traffic's liking
come on
you soon get used to the extra
checkpoints the concrete blast barriers
and that just all sort of fades away and
it just looks like a normal city but you
have to keep reminding yourself it's not
one of the biggest parts of this story
was the reality for
every gay afghans and particularly
young afghans they've you know
increasingly
become used to getting more and more
rights more and more freedoms
smells great
we make all the meals here no no
i'm a niche here and my mom and my
sister are cooking here
that cafe that we walked into you could
have found anywhere in europe you know
filled with young people
of of different ages and different sexes
and run by a woman it was pretty unheard
of in the taliban time
and quite by chance i just went up to
these two young women what did you hope
your future would be and now what are
you thinking if the taliban come back
of course we all hope that our future
must be so good but now we don't think
that we have
we will have this opportunities and all
of this
it's so
tough for us would you go
or do you feel you need to stay here and
you're the future you you guys are the
future i know i'm the future but
situation is so bad in here we just our
life we just alive not living
just keep going and don't don't know
what what what will be our future
so
if i have opportunity i will live here
but we'll come back to you there's a
whole generation of afghan women you
know 20 year olds who've grown up
with these freedoms and now we're facing
the prospect of having all these newly
won freedoms being stripped away again
by a new taliban regime
[Music]
the next bits we needed were
things that were a bit outside of our
control you know we needed the taliban
to say yes for us to go there and
everything was delaying and delay and
delaying and delaying
how you feeling
good really glad it's actually finally
happening i'm worried for the taliban
though
how you feeling
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
skye was very worried about us being
kidnapped us being killed us never
coming back us getting shot at in
crossfire
what's your name
sorry my name kevin kevin kevin i don't
want to show my face okay no no
we'd only been traveling maybe half an
hour 45 minutes and
we were forced to stop because there was
a gunfight going on on the road in front
of us there's some shooting ahead
everyone stopped on the road
[Music]
please keep your attention
it was a bit of drama at the beginning
of the trip
we got past that and we're on our way
we've passed the last government
checkpoint
so now went to taliban territory
eventually met up with the taliban yes
there are some to control this product
yes
thank you for having us
there were a few polite
niceties at the start
we just get on with filming everything
that moves did they have a fight here or
did the army leave
going on to that huge base which used to
be held by the afghan national army and
once had the americans on and seeing it
completely empty and taken over by all
these taliban fighters
if they're able to take this base
with all the weapons and all the
military vehicles that they had here
then the afghan national army has got a
very big problem
them taking us through lock up after
lock up after lockup showing how they
got all this weaponry
oh lots of
bullets
a store
rpg rpg
lots of weapons
they're all brand new what's going to
happen to all of this
that was pretty shocking that was pretty
shocking doesn't bode well for the
immediate future and certainly doesn't
shout out peace
to me
is that all right to sit there
so we've been told that um we've got
five minutes to take pictures
and then
to go to where the women are now
a large number of the men in the group
didn't want to be eating with a woman
you can't on the one hand say that
you've really changed and you've
progressed and you're very accepting of
women and you know we want women
journalists come we'll look after you
and then exclude them from meal times
it's a surreal thing having a chit chat
with the taliban under some fruit trees
in a sunny garden in the middle of
nowhere in rural afghanistan
why fighting
we're sitting with all these armed guys
and the younger ones are much happier to
talk to me i think it only works because
i'm a foreign journalist the older ones
they're very uncomfortable with the
whole idea of talking to a woman who
isn't a relative
it was good to get back to kabul hello
welcome back thanks you were brilliant
one of the most famous sayings from the
start of this whole
two-decade long conflict was
you know various taliban commanders
saying
you've got the watches
but we've got the time
you know we will just sit this out we
might not win this now but that was what
they were saying back then you know 20
years ago we'll we'll be back
after two decades of conflict costing
trillions of pounds and thousands of
deaths nato forces are slipping quietly
out of afghanistan the prime minister is
holding a meeting of the cobra emergency
committee following the taliban's rapid
advances in afghanistan truth is
this did unfold more quickly than we had
anticipated afghanistan is spinning out
of control
stewart had said to me dominique i just
have a feeling that we need to go to
afghanistan so he wrote an email to our
bosses
saying
i really feel we need to be there i
really feel like this could be another
saigon
[Music]
i guess on the one hand you really want
to go because you know that this is
going to be a huge thing don't you so
i don't actually tell most of my friends
that well i'm going to go and do these
things people who need to know need to
know so my wife obviously my parents
you know you promise to be careful um
but i don't think i don't that really
does much good
i mean as in not awfully busy
yeah obviously with kabul i know it
incredibly well so it's it's not a
strange environment for me to be in
what time is it
[Music]
7 30 okay
the travel is pretty much overnight so
you always arrive absolutely exhausted
but we knew we had to try and get
something on air as
quickly as possible
one of our producers there said there's
a park here in the center of town and
actually you can see the impact of the
taliban's advances because of all the
refugees and internally displaced people
who are living in this park there are
thousands
everyone in that park is on edge they're
traumatized and actually when you stop
and look around it's not a secure
environment
that's i think when we started to
realize that the advance wasn't just
something we sort of read on paper and
wondered if it was actually happening
but we were seeing the actual result
the real impression you get here is that
people feel that karma is being
surrounded or it's certainly going to be
in the coming weeks and of course the
situation is going to get worse food
prices are already going up petrol
prices have gone up as well and there'll
be more displaced people arriving here
and there seems nothing at this stage
obvious at least that's going to see the
taliban stopped in their tracks
recently life has become difficult for
people people worried about the how
the way taliban treated us before and
now it's a little different why should
afran people go back to the dark era
why today i'm i'm you know people like
me and thousand other people are forced
to leave this country
do you think that guy who's selling
fruits he can leave this country
there was definitely a an anxiety
about what could be coming how are
things going to go in the next days but
in people's minds we were talking days
or weeks or months
you know it became apparent to us that
the
american and british
visas being issued to translators
people who worked with all western
militaries was not going to be processed
anything like quickly enough to allow
these people to
leave so what you saw happening in kabul
were like these pop-up services at
internet cafes around the city where
people who couldn't access computers at
their homes could go to the internet
cafes and get some assistance filling
out their paperwork
they were extremely tense and very very
scared
it is our turn
to be helped
we help them you know we save their
lives
we are the people who communicate
with two cultures
otherwise without
interviewers they did nothing
so now you're abandoned and scared yes
one of the afghan local guys who works
with us said he knew a spot where you
can get up out of town you can look down
over to the airport
and get a look on what they're doing
so taliban have now taken logar
province's borders are only about 37
miles down the road behind me and it
feels inevitable now that kabul will
fall
the city is very much divided between
those who can leave or at least hope
they can leave and those who know they
can't
means this place is very tense now
you know the us had started flying in a
few extra resources and and the brits
and we'd filmed those planes and
choppers arriving at the airport
but still i think
everyone including us we're in a little
bit of denial about how fast it might be
happening
[Music]
we were already getting word that the
taliban were very near but the next day
they did actually come into town
[Music]
london it's stuart can you hear me
yeah we're still going i'm rolling in
the camera as well okay
it was a moment that many people
including myself feared because we just
didn't know what it was going to be like
i think it's a procession of
of the taliban
yes it is there's the white flag
and
they're coming down
the street
just next to us that's the point when
the city basically
started to fall apart it's like the
announcement of the endgame and it
everything changed at that moment
we went into just total rolling coverage
about a city that had just 24 hours
being pretty normal
to a city that was suddenly being taken
over
then there was a big security kerfuffle
i know the airport is busy
but
oh my god it just says
important people
attack
i was really concerned i was in danger
yeah and you go through all of these um
concerns about like what do you do
by this stage kabul is completely
surrounded
so there's a lot of tension there's a
lot of anxiety there's a bit of panic
but in that scenario i like to think
that just talking as a team you're
immediately able to bring down the
anxiety levels
after the arrival of the taliban there's
now much discussion uh as to where is
the best place to stay we're right
downtown near the presidential palace
obviously quite a long way from the
airport the airport has the security of
the american and more particularly the
british troops that are there which is
where they're doing the relief operation
nobody's sure what to do because we do
know that the road to the airport is
absolutely
rammed so there's a lot of discussion
we decided to go with the idea that
we'll pull back to the airport we'll
assess the situation but the the
thinking was that you should move now
before the taliban have organized
and had time to block off the roots of
the airport
and so we open up the gates and there's
the taliban standing right in front of
us and walking across the road
i think that drive to the airport the
potential to be the most dangerous thing
we did on the entire trip
[Music]
that you're in a window where no one's
in control
we just floored it
[Music]
not taking risks with any building but
also we're not going to stop
okay so this is chaos at the airport
it's at the airport
well that's one hell of a queue to get
to the airport down this road
how far to the baron just did it
okay
okay let's give it a couple minutes
we made it safely into the barren hotel
we did not know
the british military had pinpointed that
hotel as their evacuation point
the airport is just over this side and
the road that runs along it up to the
civilian section of the uh
airport is all controlled by the taliban
what's important about this place is
where the
british nationals and afghans who are
allowed to come to the united kingdom
our bases from here that they're moved
to those flights that take them out of
afghanistan
we start getting these pictures of the
people around this huge transporter
plane desperately trying to get through
holding on and then one or two people
falling off the plane after it's taken
off and i mean this was like oh my
goodness me this really is just utterly
horrendous
there's terribly heartbreaking and
distressing imagery of the american
plane with lots of people hanging onto
it and running alongside it on the
runway
what we didn't know was actually about
to get worse
we get up the next morning and it's
turned into a british military ford
operating base
and just there i could have reached
through the wire and touched him
a guy from the taliban
this has been absolutely chaotic for
days and days in a row and now the
taliban have come in and they are
effectively
arranging crowd control for the brits
and they're literally right next to the
soldiers i think quite a lot of them
can't quite believe what they're seeing
uh taliban openly walking around with
machine guns controlling the crowds i
think for the british forces trying to
get people out of here this is quite a
remarkable
experience to be honest you know a lot
of those people trying to leave spoke
english many of them had worked for the
british government or the military or
companies and was saying you know help
help help
one in the morning stuart pulled me
aside he said i'm going to be honest
with you this is really depressing me
dominique i'm waking up every morning to
dozens and dozens of emails from people
saying help me help me and what are we
supposed to do
alex had interviewed mawa in july she's
a younger women's rights activist and
her life was in danger once the taliban
took over of course we all hope that our
future must be so good when she appealed
for help i don't think there was anyone
in our
team who thought twice about that the
problem was practically
tried to get her to a place of safety so
i then thought the only people who could
possibly help them would be the team on
the ground so i sent her a picture of
stuart we spoke to the british soldiers
about it and you know helped identify
them in the crowd and managed to
get them through the crowd safely it's
okay they're going to bring them home
remember the soldiers are sort of one by
one bringing each family member out and
ma was saying it's that one or it's that
one and we were able to get them out and
and through
but for every one good one like that
there's dozens and dozens where we just
simply failed
by the end we probably spent more of our
time helping people than we did filming
[Music]
it seems to go in epsom flows though so
sometimes you have it like absolutely
rammed with people pushing and chaos
outside other times it sort of calms
down what happens well sometimes we can
manage to turn the crowd down using the
local nationals to calm them down when
they see the processes working they're
calm when they start getting a bit hot
dehydrated or whatever people start
getting annoyed we tend to find a lot of
the people causing the uh causing the
disturbances haven't got the correct
documentation so they're right they sort
of know the chance in their arms
and i suppose really this is all about
time isn't it you've just got to crack
on well that's it
i'm gonna be here it could be days
every day
we stepped out into that that outdoor
bit of the compound
it was like
a different
film set
how are you good good
how's it going
[Applause]
if you're in the same location every day
you want to
be able to make it look different keep
it interesting for the viewer to keep
them engaged visually so that they
listen to
the words and the story
to
that's the first time i really got to
see what was over the wall
and um
it just stops you in your tracks
stay there stay there
there's thousands and thousands and
thousands of people in the worst
possible
situation they've run for their lives
i don't know how many of those people
ever got through
the cargo containers were absolutely
correct because they they limited the
people but the effect
was like being in sort of hillsborough
[Music]
every day people came they got more and
more frustrated because they were
waiting longer and longer they had
nothing to eat they had nothing to drink
it's over 40 degrees celsius it's very
very hot
the problem now is not
trying to control the crowds per se it's
the fact that at the front people are
just getting crushed so
thousands of afghans who are coming who
have no right to come here but they're
coming anyway and they they can't just
leave them to get crushed in and the
heat is terrible and there's lots of
children so they're having to have a
sort of secondary
barrier where people who may have never
get in properly
are at least safe for the time being
it's uh
it just used to go for better worse here
and there's
i don't know
almost speechless as to what they're
going to do about it
[Music]
you're a human being on the one hand and
you want to show respect and show
decency
but on the other hand i mean there's
hardly anybody reporting from what's
happening at this stage
washington that day
there's a briefing at the state
department where they described what was
happening in the airport was congestion
and
i went out determined to make sure they
couldn't lie like that what was
happening at the airport
[Music]
there are pictures from this that we
didn't even put on air soldiers giving
cpr to people on the ground people's you
know dying right there all around us
it was pretty difficult for all of us i
think because yeah we were very tired by
this stage it's a time difference thing
as well but also we were just by
definition of what we're doing we're
working really really long hours
i'm not really sure what our governments
expected would happen when you put
thousands of people together in one
place try and pin them in and
not really know what to do with them
there's a phrase called dog and pony and
it's when you are basically given a
facility by the people you're working
with and they want to go and show you
what they're doing um and it's
you know it's essentially a pr
search exercises to come out and just do
a quick search of there you will then
get your bags back okay this isn't about
getting masses of people herding them
together and getting them onto planes
everything is about making sure we
remember that these are our friends
they're people that have worked with us
for years and we treat them in that way
student toby followed a group of
evacuees making their way to britain and
followed their journeys from leaving the
compound we were staying at
we went on to the plane with them and it
was the first time we'd seen
the process take place we knew what was
happening but we had nobody had actually
seen it before well this is it this is
where people make that final
flight out of afghanistan to countries
all over the world some of the people
here have had a hell of a journey
they've been queuing queuing for days
but they made it this is their their way
home you see these people they've just
got a small piece of hand luggage their
entire life has been left behind and
they're from the very old to tiny babies
i saw newborns being put on these planes
going into they don't know what
99.9 percent of these people probably
never even left afghanistan they
certainly not been to the uk or america
what happens to them and they're the
lucky ones
well there's a real sense now that
people beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate i mean
they're in a
sewage canal they're trying to show
their paperwork trying to show that they
perhaps should be looked at
it's really desperate that is actually
the sort of
pretty much hopeless column we're told
but i can see all sorts of passports
from different countries
the fact is that when the withdrawal
happens
it's always going to be difficult
because they can't keep working the
soldiers can't keep working up until the
last minute
they have to start withdrawing in the
days leading up to their departure
how they're going to deal with these
people when that happens we just don't
know
i mean i understood the reason they did
it
but seeing like tiny babies in that when
you know when you think about how we
treat tiny babies here it's
inconceivable
the scenes in that sewage canal were
just so desperate because there was just
something about that picture of people
standing literally knee-deep in sewage
and it really really really smelled
[Music]
they'd hold up pictures of flags of
countries just basically trying to get
the attention to say
this is the nation we're looking for and
they would try and direct soldiers
but that was the the desperation
you can imagine you have spent
hours sometimes days in these really
horrendous conditions wearing the same
clothes wearing the same shoes
having had very little sleep and now
you're about to get evacuated out of the
country
the sewage canal in those pictures to me
they tell the story about how messy
everything was
[Music]
yeah we'll go to the american section
we're going not to the bridge so you
gotta go into the right to the mate
yeah
i think what bothers me is that orders
of leave didn't come from the soldiers
on the ground at kabul
that was really bad we knew it was
coming oh he's so bloody angry
feels terrible i mean look how many
people are still here
and they're all in the sewage canal
thousands
it's heartbreaking
even if the deadline is the 31st of
august the military have to start
packing up beforehand uh the paratroop
regiment has told us that we had to
leave our location because as soon as
they finish processing we're not exactly
sure when that's going to be but it's
clearly soon they need to start the
process of withdrawing because it has to
be done assuming they could be attacked
so it's a dangerous period for them and
they've asked us to leave
and so
the question i suppose is just how many
people will they be able to get
processed and take with them that did
not sit well with any of us uh that did
not sit well with any of us at all
so we're uh we're finally on the plane
i mean everyone's still stretching and
it
is absolutely full i can't believe my
eyes
it's huge
the big um
you know
door started to come up
once the doors were up he said okay
everybody now you can all sit down
[Music]
i did feel like we failed because we'd
left i didn't want to go none of us did
is it right to me
i don't know
to be honest i don't know
[Music]
and then the bomb went off martin called
the head of security at the barron hotel
and he said there's been a suicide bomb
attack
[Music]
what haunts me now is
the people i talk to in the canal
because i think you know it was very
soon after we left and
i'm they must some of them the guys that
i spoke to they must be dead
um in the most awful way they were
having the worst possible time and then
murdered
[Music]
i couldn't have gone any higher trying
to stay
but one of us would have been outside
when that bomb went off
for certain
it was right
the
situation in afghanistan has
deteriorated no one wanted our our
engagement in our presence in
afghanistan to end
uh in the way that indeed like many
veterans this last week has been one
that has seen me struggle
through anger and grief
and rage this is all the makings of a
strategic disaster
[Music]
did
i or others think that the taliban would
take over quite so fast absolutely not
i think even the taliban to be honest
we're
pretty shocked
let's do it
let's do it
and this is just a start actually we we
can't smile until we cross the border
how far do we border x
being told varying distances
getting in this time was
complicated and
interesting the decision was made to
jump on a plane to pakistan and we would
try to go by the kyber path
you knew then going that way you were
embarking on a proper adventure
what what's your fault on coming through
man this is cool very cool i mean it's
this stuff a legend i've always wanted
to see it
it's brilliant
it's an incredibly
historic route
it's absolutely dramatically beautiful
it doesn't matter how many times you do
it it's still breathtakingly
gorgeous plus you realize you're
treading the same path that's been the
center of history and trade routes and
fighting we've just crossed over the
border from pakistan and the first thing
you see
is the white taliban flag
lots of people here waiting
um no one seems terribly happy
they're still
so unsure about how to operate this
border they still haven't got a stamp a
passport stamp saying that we've
officially arrived
is this a new weapon
it's new where did you get it from
from the americans
from the americans
i mean that whole day that whole drive
you know leaving islamabad in the
morning getting to kabul at night i mean
it was good it's a good 15-hour drive
i'm interested to see what it's going to
be like i'm very keen to see how how
they're going to be and how
um amenable they're going to be to
filming and everything we've heard some
sort of quite nasty reports about how
they've treated some of the local
journalists
but no one's had any direct experience
of it from amongst the foreign
correspondents
the reason we went to the embassies was
because we were waking up in
a new kabul at that point in time we're
thinking okay well what has happened to
these embassies you know we know they've
all been evacuated and people have left
these guys were being friendly towards
us and they've been welcoming but as
soon as i turned around to alex she said
i've just become invisible and i
suddenly looked around and she was
absolutely right none of them would
engage her in eye contact none of them
would speak to her she she basically did
not exist
it's probably one of the most
frustrating infuriating
irritating and insulting ways of being
treated when
someone thinks you're so i don't know
whether it's unimportant uninteresting
irrelevant because that's all the
messages that they're giving when
they're not looking you in in your eye
so they can come back today tomorrow
next week whenever they want
to
they want to show us how they've
destroyed alcohol in the um canadian
embassy so we'll
see what they've done there
what's your view about so much alcohol
[Music]
foreign it was a bit weird sort of
walking through these places that have
been
you know the thriving heart of
kabul diplomacy for so long and now
they're empty eerie and just sort of
taliban walking around and showing us
whatever they want to show us
yeah this is usually just complete chaos
cars everywhere
the cars honking people running into
each other and that's completely empty
and the us embassy obviously you know
with the islamic camera flag
painted in massive letters in front of
it
yeah it's crazy
we were talking some guys around there
and then some of them were getting ready
to go on a patrol so we asked could we
go on the patrol with them
and the guy said okay we'll take you on
a little patrol
you know alex is alex and she didn't
really wait
well i i first climbed into the back of
the pickup truck and then alex hopped in
after with me
we suddenly realized they were
utterly mortified at this strange woman
climbing into the back of their
of their vehicle
they're a bit scared of a woman
yeah they're very uncomfortable because
they they're not meant to associate with
a woman
as soon as i got in they all got out
they didn't even want to look at me
these guys had no idea they'd probably
never been that close to a woman in
their lives let alone a western woman
you know i have to say i thought it was
pretty funny alex less so
all we want to do is sit and take some
pictures of you doing the patrol it's
like come on
yeah it was immensely frustrating
the taliban want to show that they're in
control they're desperate for the
recognition from the international
community
before we arrived in kabul they'd been
these growing uh women's
marches sort of small protests with
women very very bravely walking through
the streets of kimball good to meet you
thank you for experiencing the time to
talk to us the journalists have been
covering women protesting for their
rights
and they'd been picked up and then
basically tortured for hours and hours
they were beaten until they went
unconscious and then they were brought
back round and then beaten again did you
think
at any stage
that you might die
my overwhelming emotion when i saw them
was how
incredibly brave they were because they
they were brave by speaking to a foreign
crew because they knew that they were
once again exposing themselves to the
possibility of being picked up again as
soon as the taliban saw this report and
they were determined to do it
and when you're standing there and
you're looking at two people who have
been beaten to that point
for doing
what essentially is my job
it makes you realize not only what you
do but also how lucky you are
it's about an hour an hour and a half
drive to get up to uh to bagram to the
air base
and we just
did what you usually do you go and knock
on the door
i've been to bagram years ago in the
early 2000s and i think anybody who's
reported from afghanistan knows about
bagram it's a massive base formerly
soviet base and then later a u.s base
we're finally in
this huge base
bingo when we got into background which
was a miracle in itself
then you're thinking okay well where do
we go
this place is 30 square miles of base
and everywhere there's a story the main
one being the detention center how do we
find it
there are containers filled with stuff
this is a portfolio stuffed full of
afghans who worked for the coalition
forces including their id numbers we
were then went further in and further in
and further in and we suddenly saw
what was quite obviously outside of a
prison with big high
towers to overlook the the courtyard
lots of barbed wire lots suddenly it
felt you were wandering into
a detention center
i don't believe anyone would construct
this for humans to be held there it's
absolutely vile
it has this eerie quality about it which
is very very difficult for me to
describe
you can see why the afghan people were
so terrified of this prison facility
these are the exercise yards the afghans
who lived around here and throughout the
country
really
thought that if they ended up in here
they would never ever get out and some
people spent years here
okay let's go down and see the um
yeah
i'm gonna end up with a broken leg
there's still there's plenty of hospital
equipment left behind that you can patch
me up with
what a horrible horrible place
it was like someone had led a trail of
breadcrumbs of evidence and we followed
it all right into the heart of this
detention center and found the storeroom
packed full of
the sort of paraphernalia of prison and
torture
what is wrong with these people
this is what they when they first
arrived this is what they were given
wasn't it so
given cable ties there's toothpaste it
was initially built and run
by the americans
then they claimed they handed it over to
afghan control but they the americans
were still there
pretty much
up until they upped and left suddenly
[Music]
the smell is quite extraordinary and in
each of these cells there's no windows
and you can completely block out
all light
with these two panels
oh my god
i mean we all went round that whole
facility pretty much whispering to each
other because it felt like
it there were all these
well to me they're all these ghosts
there
smell them again
these are the creepiest things in this
whole place
it's a pretty creepy place
blackout goggles
so that's basically to
to deprive you of sight that's sensory
deprivation alongside it there was loads
of earmuffs that you could use to
deprive people of sound and noise
those are the classic tools used in
interrogation in abuse in
the whole gamut of
horrors that you know have happened in
this place
it wasn't so much what you were seeing
in bagram it was what you were feeling
the place just emanated something
and suddenly we heard
noises upstairs
i can hear people
you've got to realize
none of the taliban knew we were there
we walk upstairs and come face to face
with a group of really shocked and
visibly upset
young
taliban fighters
i wondered why he was looking at me in a
funny way
here's a bunch of people that they may
well associate with
the suffering that they see and have
felt in the in this place
we didn't get a reaction that i expected
at all in fact
you know they were
pretty open with us very willing to
share their experience
they
spontaneously
crouched down and started praying
[Music]
many of these hardened taliban fighters
were crying
[Music]
and then when they came out after the
praying they were angry
really angry
and very emotional do you think there'll
be more suicide bombers because of what
happened here
i think you would have to be super human
to emerge from an experience like that
and not absolutely hate
the system the people the country who
put you in there
we like to think of you know the way we
behave in war as right and wrong good
and bad good guys bad guys
but actually what bagram
showed me
was that that's just not the case and
actually the reality is far more
blurred than that and much much more
complicated than we like to think
leaving was always going to be
complicated
the talking border was not an option
anymore there had been too many security
alerts around it
our only option at this point was to go
out with the qataris who were organized
in sort of repatriation flights
when we arrived there was a crowd of
people there were a lot of people were
holding up british passports american
passports they were green card holders
all trying to beg the qatari officials
to let them in to get on board a flight
out of afghanistan
australian
anyone from australia
[Music]
it's very simple
how day before how day before coming
here by passport
who had valid passport not expire who
had visa
that said he can live
that
veneer of control that the taliban had
was starting to unravel a little bit so
they weren't particularly pleased when
we started to film
the situation that they were failing to
control very well or that we were
showing how many people genuinely wanted
to leave and get out of the country
i
fixer got a bit excited and pushing and
shoving ensued and suddenly you're
realizing oh you're sort of
this close from sort of having fisty
cuffs with a taliban and you're thinking
well this isn't this isn't good
please stop yeah stop please
there's no need for this
it was giving you a sense of the general
direction of travel of in of
interactions with the taliban
what's he saying
like if you film again i will make you
guys like
i will break everything and
they're very very anxious about us not
filming and all these people are lining
outside just desperate to get out many
of them been waiting for many weeks up
to a month they tell us
this whole experience
selection process
i think we all left genuinely
concerned about the future of
afghanistan i don't think any of us
see it
flourishing in the near future
[Music]
it was very trying it was very tiring it
was very sad it was very scary at times
we thought the last 20 years was quite
eventful i think the next 20 years might
even eclipse it
there's going to be so much going on
because afghanistan is still
quite instrumental geographically in
that area
the fundamental grassroots hardcore
taliban from the countryside he ain't
changing nothing girls should not go to
school
um women shouldn't really work unless
it's in hospitals and many of them are
fundamentally conservative and super
right wing
there's some real evil nasty people
there
the whole story of afghanistan is
definitely definitely not over and i
think
we'll be spending a lot of time there in
the future
[Music]
oh
[Music]
next time on hotspots
we're in namibia where plans to drill
for oil are threatening some of the
world's most precious and endangered
wildlife we don't know what the effect
of that oil and our environment we are
afraid for that
and over a decade since an earthquake
ravaged haiti
we revisit to find a country on a knife
edge
the atmosphere was really tense
how's the bullets been fine we're trying
to clear the street
until then you can find us on twitter at
alex crawford sky and at ramsey sky
see you next time
as you are
as you were
as i want you to be
[Music]
as a friend
a friend
as an old
[Music]
you